[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure les missions qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui on vous parle des éoliennes
un sujet électrique puisque les français
ont une bonne image mais pour autant
n'en veulent pas à côté de chez eux
alors pourquoi la france est elle en
retard les éoliennes en mer sont elles
une solution d'avenir on posera la
question aux responsables de
l'observatoire des énergies
renouvelables on parlera également du
recyclage des pales un vrai casse tête
pour l'environnement heureusement les
innovations émergent vous verrez enfin
l'énergie éolienne est elle vraiment
compétitive réponse avec xavier barbaro
le pdg de neoen premier producteur
indépendant français d'énergie 100 %
renouvelable mais d'abord voici un état
des lieux des éminents france c'est
parti les éoliennes comment tout a
commencé en 1996 edf acheter à un prix
au dessus du marché et le consommateur
paye est la contribution au service
public de l'électricité la cspe prélevés
sur sa facture aujourd'hui le système
fonctionne avec des appels d'offres mais
est-ce qu'on peut installer des
éoliennes partout pour des raisons de
sécurité la moitié du territoire leur
est interdit les zones militaires ou
celle couverte par les radars impossible
aussi d'installer une éolienne à moins
de 500 mètres d'une habitation que
représente l'éolien en france on compte
plus de 15000 parc 27% se situe dans la
région de france et 22% dans le grand
est la part de l'éolien dans notre
consommation d'électricité et de 8% le
marché pèse 5,8 milliards et génère plus
de 15000 emplois directs mais au fait
quelle est la puissance d'une éolienne
une éolienne produit le maximum de ses
capacités
25 % du temps pour le terrestre et 50%
pour le off shore une éolienne à une
puissance qui peut aller jusqu'à 4,5
mégawatts sur terre et en mer jusqu'à 10
mégawatts et la suite c'est quoi
les objectifs sont ambitieux en 2023 la
puissance en éolien terrestre devra
atteindre 24 gigawatts et en 2028 autour
de 34 gigawatts
concernant l'éolien en mer emmanuel
macron a prévu 50 parc offshore d'ici
[Musique]
la france et elle a un bon ou un mauvais
élève en matière d'énergie éolienne
réponse avec frédéric tuiles et bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes responsable des
études à l'observatoire des énergies
renouvelables est ce que nous en ferons
son nez en retard ou pas sur le
développement notre parc et d'énergie
éolienne terrestre 6 terrestre à la fois
par rapport aux objectifs qu'on s'est
fixés même par rapport à certains de nos
voisins qui sont peut-être plus en
pointe que nous alors effectivement au
point de vue du point de vue des
objectifs que l'on s'est fixés la france
est en retard
actuellement nous avons un petit peu
moins de 10 9 gigawatts donc d'éoliennes
de puissance éolienne installée et 30 19
réacteurs nucléaires à peu près ça voilà
en gros à peu près voilà et en avant sur
un rythme d'environ 1 gigawatts par an
et le prochain objectif que se fixe et
donc la france c'est à la fin de l'année
2023 d'atteindre un peu plus de
vingt-quatre gigawatts donc il faudrait
quoi les deux fois plus volé deux fois
plus vite effectivement il ya
actuellement environ
2100 parcs éoliens pour dix mille cinq
cents éoliennes sur le territoire bon
qu'est ce qui bloque évidemment le sait
les riverains c'est compliqué déjà aussi
iana qu'on appelle à la lenteur
administrative
ça prend plus de temps france de sortir
une éolienne car oui oui oui alors
effectivement il donne raison j'imagine
qu'il ya des raisons parce que
effectivement la france enfin les
développeurs en france mettent souvent
ce point en avant c'est vraiment la
lenteur des services de l'état de
traiter les demandes donc obtenir le
permis construire et ensuite le
raccordement en france ça prend
6 est parfois plus sept ans alors qu'en
allemagne qui est un petit peu le le
père et ference c'est deux fois moins
long
donc c'est vraiment là dessus sur une
fluidification des procédures
administratives que portent sur tous les
desiderata des professionnels il ya les
riverains aussi qu'ils n'en veulent pas
globalement je veux dire peut pas lutter
contre les enquêtes donc ils sont faites
dans un cas d'opinion met souvent en
avant le fait que là où il ya des
éoliennes elles sont d'autant plus
acceptée par le citoyen parce qu'ils
voient que leur leurs craintes leurs
leurs desiderata autour de de
l'intégration d'éoliennes dans leur
environnement est pris en compte et que
a contrario il ya plus de crainte là où
on annonce des éoliennes parce que
finalement ils l'invitent à la réalité
n'y a pas de concertation c'est ça il
alors la concertation en france il faut
tout de même signaler que les sites
éoliens sont soumis à des contraintes
autour du développement du projet et
ensuite donc de leur de la réalisation
des chantiers à des contraintes assez
strictes et sérieuse tout par exemple
tous les sites éoliens en france sont
classées icpe donc ça là sont classées
pour la protection de l'environnement
donc au niveau de l'impact
sur le paysage un pacte vis-à-vis des
riverains
impact sur l'environnement des mesures
sont faites notamment sur le bruit et si
les donc les seuils minimum ne sont pas
respectées à ce moment là le projet ne
se fait pas mais là la contrainte
réglementaire est vraiment sérieux sur
sur l'éolien puisqu'on parle des oiseaux
les lignes électriques font plus de mal
aux oiseaux que les éoliennes c'est ce
qu'a dit d'ailleurs la ligue pour la
protection des oiseaux il ya des idées
reçues qu'on peut avoir sur le sujet
comme alors c'est vrai que on a souvent
parlé de d2 l'impact sur les oiseaux des
éoliennes est justement la ligue pour la
protection des oiseaux donne un ratio
d'environ 6 à 7 oiseaux tués par an par
une éolienne donc l'éolien terrestre
alors bon faut toujours considérer bien
sûr que c'est cet oiseau de trop mais il
yad'autres disons à actions de l'homme
qui sont plus néfastes comme par exemple
les pesticides dans l'agriculture ou le
le fait de d'artificialité des terres
qui détruit donc le milieu naturel où
vivent les oiseaux qu'un impact plus
important alors par les éoliennes
terrestres après et aussi les éoliennes
offshore en mer une première éolienne a
vu le jour en france au large de saint
nazaire est-ce que l'avenir des aliens
est plutôt en mer plus que sur terre la
nuit si les pêcheurs vous irez en mer
l'avenir il est aussi en mer et en plus
c'est complémentaire c'est à dire que
c'est vrai que le premier étage ils ont
de la fusée au yen en france comme en
europe c'était les éoliennes terrestres
parce que c'était plus simple parce que
la technologie était plus adaptée et
sans doute que le prochain étage sera
les halls et nos mères avec dans un
premier temps d'éoliennes donc posée sur
le fond marin c'est donc le cas de ce
qui se passe en ce moment ça m'a bien
près des fermes éoliennes flottantes
voilà c'est ça ça c'est le coût à le
coup suivant quand alors là en fait les
premiers en france au niveau de deux
fermes pilotes et c'est sans doute dans
sept huit ans que vers on verra les
premiers projets vraiment qui
injecteront des meilleurs batteurs sur
le réseau électrique dans l'éolien en
mer comme sur l'éolien sur terre la
réglementation a été également très très
stricte et puis il y avait beaucoup de
choses à inventer c'est à dire qu'au
niveau des procédures au niveau de
l'intégration d'éoliennes donc dans
l'écosystème marin haut niveau
effectivement de la cohabitation
d'éoliennes avec les utilisateurs de la
mer oui les pêcheurs il y avait
également aussi
modus vivendi a trouvé et
aujourd'hui la filière avance par
rapport à ces points là mais encore des
questions sont à régler c'est certain
quels sont les avantages des éoliennes
en mer par rapport aux éoliennes
terrestres plus de vent oui donc ça
c'est bien ton cas - intermittence il
n'ya pas les nuisances pour les
riverains mais on les a pour les
pêcheurs mettez c'est plus cher à
installer oui oui le coût est plus chère
à l'installation mais du fait que le
gisement éolien est bien meilleur il est
moins perturbé il n'y a pas de deux
bâtiments n'y a pas de structure pour le
couper en ce moment là on utilise donc
un indicateur qui est le facteur de
charge le facteur de charge s'est en
gros l'estimation du temps sur une année
durant lequel la machine va tourner à
plein régime donc par exemple sur terre
le facteur de charge moyen des éoliennes
en france est d'environ 27% et
aujourd'hui le facteur de charge
observée sur les fermes éoliennes en mer
en europe et les deux pratiquement 40%
donc le productible est bien meilleure
voilà et donc ce qui fait qu'au final
l'électricité à base d'éolien en mer
revient moins cher on voulait plus cher
qu alors que
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui moins cher
tout à fait moins cher alors aujourd'hui
le coup de l'éducateur éoliens en france
dont 50 l'homme voilà entre 50 70 euros
le mégawattheure et
donc dunkerque qui est un un site d'une
future ferme éolienne offshore en france
donc posé s'est soldée à moins de 40
euros le mégawattheure donc donc c'est
encore plus compétitif il a fait les
coûts d'installation d'affaires plus
important oui oui oui très compétitif
les énergies renouvelables les plus
développés 1 comme l'éolien le
photovoltaïque sont aujourd'hui à des
coûts au niveau du kilowattheure très
compétitif ou et je reviens à l'objectif
de la france en 2050 ont évoqué en
éolien ses 40 gigawatts
ça sera quoi fifty-fifty moitié moitié
entre le l'éolien et le solaire et
encore une fois il faut largement en
fera le lien entre l'éolien terrestre et
l'éolien en mer offshore
il encore il faut accélérer à fond quoi
oui il faut accélérer à fond d'autant
plus que au delà des objectifs qui sont
fixés actuellement par un texte qu'on
appelle la ppe la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie c'est un
texte national qui fixe les objectifs
pour l'ensemble en fait deux de
l'énergie en france un pas uniquement
des dons qu'ils énergies renouvelables
l'éolien mais au-delà de ça par exemple
les scénarios qu'en été sorti par rte en
fin d'année dernière montre que dans
tous les cas au niveau d'électricité
française au niveau du mix électrique
france il faudra il faudra accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
y relate rancio nage tout à fait et
respecter les accords de paris vous
remercie beaucoup frédéric thil est donc
le responsable études à l'observatoire
des énergies renouvelables merci à vous
on va s'intéresser au printemps à
l'impact environnemental des éoliennes
et vous allez voir des progrès restent à
faire en matière de recyclage manuel
aigre
en 20 ans près de 8000 éoliennes ont été
déployés sur le territoire français
certaines arrivent en fin de vie à
partir de 2025 300 à 500 d'entre elles
devront être démantelées chaque année et
ces chiffres ne vont qu'augmenter
certaines pièces de ces éoliennes ne
sont pas recyclables et les déchets
risquent de s'accumuler sur notre
planète
[Musique]
du côté de la défense angie le numéro un
français de l'éolien terrestre a décidé
de réagir pour éviter que cette énergie
verte ne soit boudée par les français
nous sommes arrivés à un point où il est
devenu évident que l'éolien représentera
un pilier de la transition énergétique
par conséquent il est devenu évident que
nous aurons besoin de plus en plus
d'éoliennes en france en europe dans le
reste du monde et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous souhaitons oeuvrer pour
tendre vers 100 % de recyclabilité
sept tonnes près de 90 mètres de long
l'apal est l'élément de l'éolienne qui
pose problème
c'est elle qui n'est pas totalement
recyclable
mais angie a décidé de contre-attaquer
en s'associant à des ingénieurs nantais
et c'est ici à l'abri des regards que se
joue très certainement l'avenir de nos
éoliennes
on travaille sur le développement d'une
pâle sans qu'on soit cyclable en gros
challenge
aujourd'hui la moitié de la pallée
composé de fibre de verre et de résine
un mélange qui pose problème
une fois qu'ils sont ensemble ils vont
complètement se solidifier et c'est le
problème actuellement c'est que ces deux
matériaux on n'arrive pas à les séparer
on se retrouve avec un matériau non
recyclables qu'on va devoir en fruits
roues ou incinérés alors pour atteindre
l'objectif d'une pâle 100% recyclable
les ingénieurs continuent d'utiliser ce
tissu en fibre de verre mais vole
associée à une autre résine spécialement
développé pour les éoliennes une recette
tenue secrète alors nous la solution
qu'on apporte c'est que j'ai une résine
thermoplastique et on va là la lier à la
fibre de verre et l' avantage c'est
qu'on va pouvoir la séparait de la fibre
de verre par procédés chimiques ou
thermiques et que cette résine là on va
pouvoir la réutiliser pour refaire une
pole parce qu'elle va conserver ses
propriétés mécaniques même après la
séparation avec le tissu de fibre de
verre des pales d'éoliennes recyclable à
l'infini
et ce n'est pas tout
ou alors en train
des trajectoires théorie
c'est pas ne serait pas uniquement écolo
lors de leur démantèlement mais dès leur
conception et ce grâce à des robots
l'intérêt gérer c'est d'automatiser donc
le procédé donc d'utiliser les matériaux
recyclables et de les mettre en oeuvre
pour limiter les chutes donc le robot
nous permet effectivement de dérouler la
quantité de matière qui suffit par
rapport à la largeur de de l'apal
aujourd'hui si on veut réaliser donc des
productions grande cadence ça nécessite
effectivement d'optimiser ses matériaux
et c'est une des bonnes façons
effectivement pour réaliser donc le
départ de manière durable en limitant la
consommation des ressources c'est vrai
pour les tissus mais c'est vrai aussi
pour les résidants
étaient bien là les couples
après un an de recherche et 18 millions
d'euros sur la table la première balle
de 62 mètres 100 % recyclable a vu le
jour
jusqu'à la fin de l'année elle va subir
une batterie de tests
et si elle répond parfaitement au cahier
des charges
1500 pâle comme celle-ci sortiront
chaque année des usines dès 2024
[Musique]
mais pour alexandre roche délégué
général du syndicat des énergies
renouvelables
si les industriels s'acharne à réaliser
des éoliennes recyclables ce n'est pas
uniquement par conviction dans la
réglementation aujourd'hui il y a une
obligation de recycler 90 % de la masse
d'une éolienne ça c'est une obligation
qui va débuter au 1er juillet prochain
et au 1er juillet 2024 ce sera 95 % de
la masse d'une éolienne qui devrait être
recyclé donc on voit qu'en fait le
secteur et la réglementation ont évolué
de manière parallèle et que on va aller
faire des éoliennes quasiment 100%
recyclable ça va devenir la norme à
l'avenir les éoliennes bientôt 100 %
recyclables sur terre et en mer et qui
seront peut-être aussi plus efficiente
des projets sont actuellement en cours
pour produire des éoliennes nouvelle
génération plus grande et plus
productive l'objectif réduire de moitié
leur nombre tout en produisant plus
d'électricité
[Musique]
allez on continue à parler des éoliennes
en france avec un acteur majeur chez
nous ici c'est xavier barbaro pour newen
bonjour aujourd'hui un petit chèque
installez-vous 7 le pdg de neoen les
bois il faut expliquer un premier
producteur indépendant français
d'énergie 100 % renouvelable
trente trois parcs éoliens dans le monde
implantées essentiellement en australie
en finlande et en france qu'est ce que
vous faites concrètement sur un champ
d'éoliennes ou fabriquer les éoliennes
d'un spa ou de fabriquer les fait à peu
près tout le reste sir que nous on est à
l'origine du projet donc on va trouver
les terrains on obtient des permis fait
le montage industriel le montage
financier mais on sait d'où viennent
elles nous sont fournies par des acteurs
comme general electric vestas siemens
donc on les fait construire et ensuite
on les exploite voilà et les miles et
les pales qu'on voit tous ses produits
en france d'ailleurs alors plutôt en
europe il ya des composants français il
ya surtout des travaux d'ailleurs qui
sont fait évidemment par des entreprises
locales en mai ont globalement la
française c'est une industrie européenne
mais qui est assez peu française pour la
partie visible après à nouveau le que ce
soit l'ingénierie ou la construction là
c'est très français et à qui elle est
revendue derrière après cette énergie
lait vendus à des entreprises des
particuliers pour l'instant en france
elle est mise dans le pot commun avec
edf qui agit comme chambre compensation
serre que nous on envoie des factures
edf est ensuite edf envoie ses électrons
dans le réseau est aujourd'hui cette
électricité qui est dans le pot commun
elle est assez compétitive et donc
contrairement à l'image d'épinal qui est
resté aujourd'hui l'éolien tire les prix
vers le bas qu'en france ça coûte
combien de produire d'électricité à base
d'éolien parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
chiffres qui circulent il yal'un telle
est la question de l'intermittence la
permanence le fait qu'une éolienne ne
tourne pas toute la journée mais elle
tourne quoi 25 30% du temps en fait
elles tournent à peu près tout le temps
ah mais rarement à pleine puissance donc
taire quand on veut résumer ça on dit
qu'une éolienne elle va tourner 20 ou
25% du temps donc c'est parfait non
c'est une autre manière de le présenter
c'est comme si elle tournait 25% du
temps à plein régime en réalité elle
tourne quasiment 100% du temps à 20 ou
30 ou 40% de son maximum mais en fait
c'est assez homogène dans le temps et en
plus comme il ya en france plusieurs
bassins devant différents la production
éolienne est relativement régulière et
d'en cas n'est aujourd'hui plus
compétitif cette énergie éolienne
énergie qui est moins cher à produire et
si on compare par rapport ce n'est pas
moi au nucléaire qui est déjà amorti par
rapport au monde urbina gaz quelques
repères aujourd'hui neoen et d'autres
acteurs en france à faire des électrons
éolien à peu près à 50 60 euros par
mégawattheure sas et nos unités de
compte mais pour les rendre plus
lisibles pour comparer à ce qui ce fait
d'autres aujourd'hui les marchés
d'électricité en france sont à peu près
à 200 voyez donc on est quasiment c'est
une situation qui est un peu normal
aussi voilà certes mais quand on regarde
le coût du nucléaire déjà amortis
aujourd'hui ses 46 euros et edf dit que
c'est pas assez vous voyez on est à peu
près nous avec d'une nouvelle éolien au
prix du nucléaire déjà amortis et quand
on regarde le nouveau nucléaire on a des
références par exemple les recteurs
produit construit par edf au royaume uni
c'est à peu près deux fois le prix de
l'éolien en france donc l'éolien
aujourd'hui c'est le prix de l'ancien
nucléaires déjà amortis et c'est la
moitié du prix du nouveau nucléaire
c'est important d'être capable de faire
de l'éolien en france parce qu'il ya un
gros potentiel il faut faire ça bien les
gens ont le droit d'être contre après il
faut pas non plus que les projets soient
bloqués parfois par une poignée
d'opposants il faut trouver un bon
équilibre entre ne pas faire n'importe
quoi ne pas aller planter des éoliennes
en face du mont saint-michel je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord ou presque tous
d'accord en tout cas nous on pense que
c'est une mauvaise idée est à l'envers
c'est pas parce qu'à en opposant qu'il
faut aussi s'interdire de faire un
projet après une éolienne qui fait la
taille de la tour montparnasse
comprenez que des riverains pour le coup
ne veulent pas sachant qu'elles peuvent
être à 500 mètres d'une habitation
théorique c'est trop proche évidemment
et donc alors c'est assez rare
d'éoliennes qui font la taille de la
tour montparnasse et en bout de pale ont
donc le la partie le main et ce qu'on
appelle la nacelle un qui est la partie
qui contient les équipements électriques
ça ça se situe à 80 90 ans on va mettre
c'est déjà beaucoup comment est ce qu'on
fait pour que ces éoliennes encore une
fois que ces nuisances sonores visuelles
c'est tous les mêmes griefs qui rayonne
qui revient de la part des riverains
alors que ce soit accepter encore une
fois où est ce que la réalité c'est
qu'en général ces paysages et alors
parfois le lait les gens utilisent
plusieurs arguments le gros sujet c'est
les questions de visibilité le bruit
objectivement il y en a quand même pas
beaucoup après ya beaucoup de mythes
autour de l'éolien que ça émettrait des
infrasons des choses qui sont un peu un
peu virtuel mais ce qui est vrai c'est
que il ya des choses des règles
auxquelles on est soumis qui est d'abord
de présenter notre projet de rencontrer
les riverains de faire des séances
publiques nous on essaie d'aller au delà
de ça sert que parfois quand il ya dans
un projet éolien de neoen une éolienne
ou deux éoliennes qui font
particulièrement débat nous ans est
enlevée celles qui font peut-être le
plus de le plus de problèmes non voilà
il ya une attitude responsable pour un
acteur comme nous mais il y aura
toujours des opposants et il faut pas
non plus écouté que des opposants du
fait de cette intermittence est permis
tant ce qui existe avec les éoliennes il
faut parfois aussi s'appuyer sur des
énergies fossiles encore une fois qu'ils
sont pas propres comme le gaz est ce que
c'est pas un peu la limite aussi des
éoliennes actuellement puisqu'il faut un
backup comment dit ouais je voudrais un
peu cassé quand même ce cette idée parce
que il ya un raccourci un peu facile qui
est dire il ya de l'hydraulique en
france qui est disponible dans des
volumes importants qui est évidemment
100% verte 100% bleus moyens et qui
serait au service du nucléaire est par
contre l'intermittence du renouvelable
que ce soit l'éolien le solaire la il
faudra résoudre sein avec des avec des
moyens thermiques du gaz ou du diesel la
réalité c'est que il ya besoin d'avoir
des moyens flexible non seulement pour
l'intermittence du renouvelable mais
aussi pour
le contraire en fait qu'elle nucléaire
qui lui ne s'est jamais s'arrêter ou ne
sait jamais vraiment ce module et on a
besoin de flexibilité dans le système
cette flexibilité elle peut venir de
l'hydraulique l'hydraulique pourrait
tout aussi bien être au service du
renouvelable comme elle l'est
aujourd'hui au service du nucléaire la
flexibilité elle vient aussi d
interconnexion avec d'autres pays on
peut se passer des électrons d'un pays à
l'autre et plus la flexibilité
elle vient aussi de quelque chose qui
est nouveau et qui est très prometteur
qu'est la capacité de piloter un peu la
demande c'est-à-dire côté client côté
industriel côté résidentiel la capacité
à baisser si nécessaire un peu notre
consommation et donc à mieux vivre avec
l'intermittence du renouvelable quand
vous dites que c'est compétitif l'éolien
vous prenez en compte aussi le coût
complet à savoir le coût de stockage de
cette électricité ou pas alors à nouveau
il n'y a pas forcément besoin de la
stocker puisque le les bassins devant en
france on a cédé corrélés l'éolien quand
on regarde la production éolienne en
france elle est finalement restée
régulière elle n'est pas complètement
près des bassins certains bassins
compense d'autres ouais vous avez la
vallée du rhône vous avez la bretagne
vous avez les hôtes france tout ça tout
ça finalement mon produit à des moments
différents mais mais ce lit ça c'est
bien tout ce dont vous n'avez pas
forcément besoin de stocker cette
énergie sur le modèle économique on a
rien dit il ya beaucoup de dettes
j'imagine pour financer ses
infrastructures
il ya des il ya une garantie de prix
avec l'état ces complexes ou pas comme
modèle économique le terme de garantie
est un peu trompeur au sens l'état nous
fait pas forcément une faveur donc on a
des contrats nous avec l'état des
contrats qui sont longs comme ces
contrats sont longs avec des cash-flows
garantie on peut assez facilement se
financer mais ces contrats ils sont
quand même dans l'intérêt des deux
parties c'est que nous on vend de
l'électricité de manière assez
prévisible et c'est très bien pour notre
capacité à nous financer mais
symétriquement les temps c'est qu'il va
pouvoir acheter l'électricité je vous le
disais à 60 euros par mégawatt heure
pendant 15 ans et c'est la bonne
électricité verte et pas cher c'est une
pépite française née au n en finit là
dessus mais ils se regardent et beaucoup
de gens de l'énergie qui lorgne sur voie
gourmandise en pense évidemment total
énergie mais pas que vous avez les
moyens de financer votre croissance tout
en restant indépendant nous on a la
chance d'avoir un actionnariat qui est
stable qui est de qualité et
qui capable de réinvestir notre premier
actionnaire impala donc la société de
jacques veyrat et de sa famille à peu
près 45 % du capital de neoen on a une
société aussi qui a comme actionnaire
bpi france le fsp dont des assureurs
font donc la question qui se pose pas à
court terme société qui est côté on a
levé je peux dire fascinant n'insultons
pas l'avenir mais on a levé 600 millions
d'euros sur les marchés en 2021 la
demande était était vraiment là pour
participer à la croissance de neoraine
merci des barreaux merci david et bien
figurez vous que les éoliennes ne pousse
pas seulement dans les champs mais aussi
sur le toit des immeubles dans nos
villes
[Musique]
et oui c'est le pari de la start-up une
école dans les outrances nous proposer
les éoliennes en milieu urbain bonjour
et milan david voir c'est quoi le
principe de ces mini éoliennes alors
l'idée c'est de récupérer le vent qui
s'engouffre sur le toit de nos immeubles
un gisement vierge est complètement sous
exploitées qui pourrait permettre bien
aux villes de produire leur propre
énergie alors vous le voyez ces
éoliennes elles sont compactes elles
mesurent à peine trois mètres de haut
elles n'ont pas de mât elles se posent
directement sur les toits des immeubles
ce qui permet de ne pas défigurer les
paysages et ses tourments vie donc
forcément il ya moins de dégâts sur les
espaces naturels enfin elles sont
silencieuses et ne provoquent aucune
vibration donc elle pourrait presque
réconcilier les pro et les anti éoliens
a effectivement certaines associations
d'anti les suivent sur les réseaux
sociaux et même xavier bertrand vous
savez qui est connu pour ses positions
anti éoliennes s'y intéresse et puis ces
éoliennes elles ont un autre atout qui
pourrait permettre de convaincre les
plus récalcitrants elles sont fabriquées
non pas avec des matériaux extraits de
manière polluantes à l'autre bout du
monde mais avec de l'inox et de l'alu de
seconde main qui sont récupérés dans des
usines juste à côté du nord et du pas de
calais alors c'est très bien de prendre
des matériaux qui sont recyclées mais
une fois que les reviennent arrive en
fin de vie pour le coup là elle devient
coin eh bien figurez vous que ces
éoliennes elles ont été conçues pour
tourner à l'infini la seule pièce
d'usure finalement ce sont les
roulements qui fera peut être changer au
bout de quarante ans mais c'est très
facile quelques boulons à enlever pour
quelques euros et le tour est joué votre
éolienne est reparti pour durer 40 ans
de plus bon emilie on voit bien que les
toits sont désormais un terrain de jeu
idéal justement de quelle est la
puissance qu'on a que l'on peut
récupérer est-ce que les immeubles
peuvent vraiment pour le coup
fonctionner de manière totalement
autonome j'arrive vous dire ça dépend de
là où vous trouver car vous soyez dans
la creuse ou à dunkerque la carte des
vents n'est pas la même concrètement les
zones propices c'est tout le nord de la
france 1 de brest à dunkerque vous avez
également l'ouest de brest à bordeaux la
normandie une partie de la région
parisienne la côte landaise et puis les
bouches du rhône avec marseille qui est
un petit peu une ville béni avec du
soleil et du vent toute l'année en
revanche le vent souffle peu dans le
centre vous aurez donc du mal à récolter
suffisamment d'énergie pour vous
alimentez qui pour répondre à votre
question david sur la puissance avec
c'est un petit peu difficile de faire
une généralité on va dire que installé
dans une zone bien exposé une mini
éolienne pourra produire grosso modo
milko de kilowattheures par an 1000
kilowatts suis pas sûr que ce soit
suffisant pour rendre autonomes animaux
but alors justement pour améliorer leur
performance et éoliennes sont
aujourd'hui associé à des panneaux
photovoltaïques sur des plates formes
mixtes que l'on installe donc sur les
toits des immeubles la seule contrainte
c'est que les toits soit plat et c'est
malin au passage puisque ces deux
énergies soleil et vent sont on le sait
complémentaire à exactement l'idée c'est
de profiter l'énergie du soleil au beau
jour donc au printemps et en été puis
ensuite en automne et en hiver ce sont
les éoliennes qui prennent le relais le
résultat de la société générale une
école est bien c'est de l'énergie
quasiment tout le temps de jour comme de
nuit et surtout une facture
d'électricité en baisse comptez entre 7
et 12 centimes le kilowattheure contre
18 à 22 actuellement en tout cas dans
les zones évidemment où les conditions
climatiques sont réunis après il faut
évidemment l'avant les moyens car pour
une installation il faut compter entre
100 et 150 mille euros tout de même ce
système il marche emilie qu'on soit en
immeuble ou en maison alors la société
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui aux
immeubles mais ces éoliennes elles
pourraient s'intégrer dans des zones
pavillonnaires en construction d'autant
que dans quelques années la
réglementation imposera aux maisons
neuves de produire l'énergie qu'elle
consomme vous voyez c'est les mini
éoliennes auront sans doute un rôle à
jouer dans un futur proche elle aussi
merci mais les gars il a dit allez
pourvu que ça dure les missions qui rend
les co-responsables c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui émission à voir ou revoir
sur public sénat ou en replay sur
publicsenat.fr rendez vous dans deux
semaines pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]